[Music]
on this thursday night covet 19
outbreaks in the oil sands
this is an epicenter of disease why the
problem extends beyond alberta's borders
vaccination acceleration the new
shipments of shots coming and who will
soon be eligible
deepening desperation in the world's
worst covet hot spot
cases are skyrocketing here how
canadians are rallying to help india
and democracy's new demographic it's
only right that they do
have a voice the teenagers who get to
vote in wales and the potential ripple
effects worldwide
plus oh baby the surprises
delivered to one overwhelmed mom
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with good news and bad news
about covid19 in canada
the good news is about the progress on
vaccines with more doses arriving and in
the pipeline provinces are ramping up
their rollouts to
younger canadians the bad news the virus
is still spreading faster in some
provinces than vaccines are arriving
manitoba reported its biggest daily
spike in more than four months today
363 new cases nova scotia broke its
daily record for the third day in a row
with 182 new infections
nova scotia now has more active cases
per capita than
quebec but the hardest hit province by
far
remains alberta 546 of every 100 000
people
are known to be infected right now the
worst affected region
is wood buffalo that's home to fort
mcmurray in canada's oil sands
where thousands of people work and live
more than a dozen
outbreaks have made more than a thousand
people sick
and since workers fly in and out from
other parts of canada the problem
is not alberta's alone heather urex west
has our top story tonight
the kovit 19 outbreak at the canadian
natural resources horizon
oil sands worksite has now become the
country's largest single outbreak since
the pandemic began
1093 people have become sick
and two of those workers have died this
isn't just something happening
in one remote isolated community in
northern alberta
this is an epicenter of disease that's
radiating and affecting
communities coast to coast with
outbreaks now active at more than a
dozen oil sands work sites
alberta senator paula simon says it's
time for a coordinated
national response oil sands operations
and the work camps that support them
were deemed an essential service in
alberta and are not subject to new
restrictions that require
any workplace with more than 10 coveted
infections be shut down
instead the industry is relying on
vaccines partnering with alberta health
services to deliver mass vaccination
clinics to workers
on site the first ones have already
taken place
cnrl horizon has had a clinic this last
weekend
there are two aspects to vaccinating our
way out one is ensuring that everybody
gets the shot
infectious diseases expert craig jenny
says when it comes to work
camps the variants have made it nearly
impossible to contain
viral spread vaccinations will help but
only if nearly all workers participate
and even then it will take two weeks
before workers
are protected so between now and then
unfortunately we can expect the virus to
continue
to to spread through these populations
of course these populations are not
confined to northern alberta alone
most of newfoundland's coveted
infections have been imported and with
so many workers flying to oil sands
sites
officials there are on alert anxious
that alberta's coveted crisis could
spread
heather urex west global news calgary
on a positive note alberta is reporting
major progress with its vaccine rollout
this morning bookings open to people
thirty years and over and according to
premier jason kenny in less than five
hours one hundred thousand people had
booked their shots
overall in canada more than forty one
percent of adults have now had at least
one vaccine dose that number is expected
to rise quickly
with 25 million doses expected in canada
by the end of the month
i think if we look in the coming weeks
and months
we'll have sufficient quantity of doses
for provinces and territories to offer a
vaccine to all those
canadians who want it perhaps sooner
than originally anticipated
it is the responsibility of the
provinces and territories to get the
doses to canadians
while each is handling the rollout in
their own way there is a growing sense
of optimism
everywhere here's eric sorenson
if you're living in a region like peel
where more than 600 new cases are
reported day after day for weeks
or in alberta where hospitalizations are
rising to crisis levels
it's hard to see light at the end of the
tunnel restrictions remain necessary
but vaccines may be starting to turn the
tide to see something like this really
does provide that you know shimmering
light at the end of the tunnel
in hot spots like peel the lineups are
long as more vaccine clinics pop
up and now anyone over 18 is eligible to
book an appointment
people are locked up so you know having
the back seat in place
definitely adds some ease and peace of
mind to the communities the numbers by
age groups demonstrate the impact
vaccines are already having
since december in ontario the percentage
of people who received at least one dose
has risen steadily by age group to more
than 80 percent of those
over aged 80 who've received a shot over
the same four months
the number of covid cases have fallen
off dramatically
the older the age group a sign that
vaccines are making a big difference
there is something profound about taking
these vaccines to protect yourself and i
think this data is showing it the influx
of more than 2 million doses a week this
month
is energizing provinces to expand their
programs
quebec will join other provinces to give
first shots to 12 to 17 year olds
before the end of the school year even
issuing a challenge to young people
i think they want to see their friends
and the best way to do it is to get
vaccinated
please show older people that you are
better than we are
it is incredibly encouraging to see our
immunizations going up
and our rates of transmission ever so
slowly
bending down it doesn't mean lockdowns
are finished yet
ontario health officials don't expect
much to open up before the end of may
we don't want to open prematurely and
end up with a fourth wave
that is the last thing we need but even
in peel where the pandemic has been so
difficult
there is a sense of purpose everybody
should get vaccinated
to get this country back where it was
before i think everywhere
everywhere across the country i think
there's this uh i think there's new
energy in this new optimism
optimism that is building with the
arrival of each new shipment of vaccines
eric sorensen global news toronto
canada is joining talks to waive patent
protections for covid19 vaccines
yesterday the us government announced it
is supporting the idea of easing world
trade organization rules
a waiver could eventually help boost the
global vaccine supply
and make it easier for developing
countries to get the expertise
supplies and ingredients needed to make
their own vaccines
but that will take a lot of money and a
long time
canada's international trade minister
mary ing says equitable access to
vaccines
is critical we agree the pandemic isn't
over anywhere
until it is over everywhere and we will
continue to work with
our international partners towards a
speedy and a just recovery
the pharmaceutical industry says a
waiver would undermine the development
of
innovative drugs a veteran canadian
intelligence officer is slamming his
employer for initially refusing to have
a mandatory masking
policy canada's security intelligence
service ces only recently made it a
requirement
after its headquarters was already hit
by outbreaks of covid19
with reporting by stuart bell jasmine
pasano has the story of one man's fight
to keep himself
and his colleagues safe
as someone whose job it is to keep
secrets gary voss smith may be the last
person you'd expect to see on national
tv
doing this is a big jump for me talking
to the media but
he's now decided to make his fight
public the culture is there
the culture is there not to speak loudly
about
things certainly not about work this is
different this this is a pandemic
and this is lethal many of his
colleagues work on sensitive files
so they have to come into the office and
for months
voss smith pushed for everyone at
cesar's headquarters to wear a mask
but in november 2020 a supervisor had
suggested he was being disrespectful
though ceases told global news employees
have been free
and encouraged to give their input on
workplace safety measures
we hear time and again from the
governments that we're in this together
and it didn't feel like that when i was
facing reprisals
the mask is profound but it's so simple
to impose
just wear a mask in december ceases
director david vigno wrote an email to
vos smith
saying most employees have opted to wear
non-medical masks in the common areas
and he does not consider that mandatory
enforcement is required
but fast forward to march when ces was
hit with covet 19 outbreaks and news
emerged that vino himself
had tested positive though the agency
said he was infected outside the
workplace
the next month cesis finally required
all employees to wear a mask
he would have had a significant risk
reduction
if they would have had masking all along
the agency told global news that since
the beginning of the pandemic
it's been following the guidance and
advice of the public health agency of
canada
cesas also said it's been taking
measures including hand washing and
physical distancing
to prevent the spread of kova 19. this
is not
a national security issue this is a
health and safety issue
vos smith adds that his story shows css
employees are no different than anyone
else trying to stay
safe jasmine pizano global news
toronto in india
the situation is still getting worse in
the last 24 hours more than 412
000 people have tested positive for
covet 19
and nearly 4 000 more people are known
to have died from the virus
health experts say the real numbers
could be as much as 10 times higher
than the official tallies the whole
world is watching this including
millions of people in canada
many of whom have family and friends in
india as robin gill explains they are
stepping up
to help ankita grover went to india to
check on her family
between travel bans imposed by that
country and canada
the manitoba resident is trapped and
desperate to get out with her daughter
cases are increasing day by day and we
cannot go outside
waranjit sidhu of british columbia went
to india for his mother-in-law's funeral
now he's stuck we're getting worried
more because as
cases are getting higher higher and
higher
the images of the dead and dying in
india are heartbreaking
being here in canada you do feel a
little bit helpless but canada's south
asian community
is rallying to donate to aid
organizations
khalsa aid has been using the donations
to buy ventilators and oxygen
concentrators
these precious pieces of cargo are
headed to the world's coveted 19 hot
spot where they're in short supply
the output from the community has been
great not only in a
donation and financial perspective but
also there's been a lot of emotion
time is of the essence in this part of
the world the peak of india's second
wave
isn't expected until the end of may and
medical supplies
are desperately needed from her home in
toronto
thirty-five-year-old as winnie sivaraman
has frantically been coordinating with
her friends and family back in india as
i'm combing through
you know the sos calls for help and so
on
is that people are in need of different
medical supplies whether it's oxygen or
blood
she's doing the research to make sure
the donations are reaching legitimate
organizations
because there's so little trust in the
indian government
the canadian government has committed 10
million to the indian red cross
and is encouraging donations to other
canadian aid groups
giving it to organizations here and
gives you a certain more transparency
there's no shortage of people who want
to help but the help needs to get there
sooner rather than later
the situation is getting worse here day
by day with a husband and father waiting
back in canada
this mother and daughter are even more
anxious to get home
robin gill global news vancouver
prime minister justin trudeau's chief of
staff katie telford is expected to
appear before the house of commons
defense committee
investigating sexual misconduct in the
military
global news has learned telford offered
to appear tomorrow
after a formal push from conservative
mps and a failed motion demanding she be
fired
conservatives allege telford was in
their words complicit in hiding the
truth from canadians when she didn't
tell trudeau about the 2018
allegation of inappropriate behavior
against canada's former top soldier
general jonathan vance
vance denies all allegations of
inappropriate behavior
violence on the streets of colombia
[Applause]
coming up what protesters across that
country are demanding
plus one of rio de janeiro's deadliest
shootouts
at least 25 people including a police
officer have been killed in a shootout
in rio de janeiro it happened during an
operation against drug
traffickers in the city's third largest
slum a local tv station captured footage
of suspects trying to escape
police say at least 10 people have been
arrested rio de janeiro is one of
brazil's most violent regions
vast areas are under control of
criminals this is one of the deadliest
police raids in the city's recent
history
for the ninth straight day thousands of
colombians took to the streets in
nationwide protests
the demonstrations started in opposition
of a now canceled tax reform plan and
they've involved into a broader protest
against poverty excessive use of force
by the police and the
inequalities in the health and education
systems violent clashes have broken out
between police and protesters at least
24 people have died though that number
is disputed
by human rights groups who say the real
toll is higher
a woman from mali has given birth to
nine babies that's only
known to have happened twice before in
recorded history
[Applause]
the woman is 25 years old she was
expecting seven babies that's what the
ultrasound
showed but there were nine all of them
delivered by c-section
at a hospital in morocco doctors say
they weigh between 1.1 and 2.2 pounds
each and will be in incubators for some
time
but for now the girls and boys and their
mother are doing well
how one long promised icebreaker turned
into two
the politics of shipbuilding just ahead
there is news tonight about the
long-promised plan to build new ships in
canada
including a long overdue polar
icebreaker federal shipbuilding is
highly political
big promises are often made and big
contracts get doled out and
sometimes they even get snatched away
before anything is built
our chief political correspondent david
aiken has the details of what promises
were made today
david well donna at one time the federal
government was going to build just
one heavy icebreaker and with a price
tag of likely
two billion dollars or more that would
have been quite the reward for the
shipyard and region that won that
contract
but rather than create winners and
losers in what could be an election year
the federal liberals have decided to
build not one
but two heavy icebreakers one
at the c-span shipyard in north
vancouver
it's fantastic news super excited to
keep our members working
long-term employment and it's obviously
good for the lower mainland and the west
coast in general
the second at the davy shipyard in the
quebec city region
picking two winners to split
multi-billion dollar contracts
each with thousands of potential jobs
helps the trudeau government avoid
political headaches
in bc and quebec though the liberals
deny
politics played a role in the icebreaker
contracts
of course we all defend our different
industries our own provinces
but this is the responsible and
necessary decision that we had to make
because we need those two ships
this isn't politics this is about
actually giving the men and women of the
coast guard
the tools they need to do the job that
canadians expect them to do
the opposition says the decision to
build two in two shipyards
well that's pure politics i said okay we
will invent another one
we will make two icebreakers instead of
one and we will promise
quebec city that they will have it it's
another election announcement
david it's something that's geared
towards an election wherever that may be
now we're not going to see any of these
icebreakers until
2030 but if there's an election in 2021
you may not hear much about that donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thank you
newfoundland and labrador is in
desperate financial shape and today a
long-awaited report called
the big reset lays out the harsh
realities and calls
for higher taxes and spending cuts the
premier's economic recovery team
recommends deep spending cuts to health
care and education
privatizing some public agencies
increasing income tax
and creating a wealth and second home
tax the aim would be to return to a
balanced budget in six years
newfoundland and labrador has the
highest per capita expenditures and
net debt of any province in the country
it is at risk
of not being able to pay salaries or
operate hospitals
the economic recovery team is also
calling on the government to dismantle a
provincial energy corporation which
oversees the troubled muskrat falls
hydroelectric project
and with one of the largest public
sectors in canada it says the provincial
government needs to re-evaluate its
relationship
with unions i'm crystal gabanzing in
cardiff wales for the first time
16 and 17 year olds are casting ballots
how voters and candidates are reacting
to the historic change
the right to vote is an essential part
of democracy and there's long been
debate including here in canada
about lowering the voting age that's
already happened in wales and scotland
for the first time 16 and 17 year olds
are able to vote in welsh parliamentary
elections
and it's given thousands of young people
a direct say in their future
it's hoped it will also increase
political engagement
crystal gomencing explains
the senate country overlooks cardiff bay
and
change is on the horizon no one
anticipates a parliamentary
shake-up still this election is historic
voters as young as 16 are casting
ballots
it can be so frustrating that you're so
ignored
and you're so unable to have a say yeah
it breeds apathy
we know that the people that vote the
most are often
the oldest harvey jones is 22
he became a candidate in bridgend to
steer policies towards issues important
to his
generation educational supports housing
and mental health initiatives extending
the franchise to as many people as
possible
is a really sensible move particularly
when we have so many 16 17 year olds
working
paying taxes going into the military
it's only right that they do
have a voice wales followed scotland
in granting young people that voice the
electoral reform society
continues to lobby for the voting age to
be reduced
across the uk we've seen over the last
year young people protesting around
climate change around black lives matter
things like that relate massively to the
decisions made in our welsh parliament
and young people 16 17 year olds and
above should have their voices heard on
those issues
there is also a vote 16 campaign in
canada and it has some political support
in bc
what's happening here is being closely
watched because it could lead to a
new more inclusive political era does it
have an effect in which it changes the
tone the tenor
and more important the look of politics
so it isn't
as the old cliche goes dominated by male
pale and stale even if this one doesn't
necessarily show the uptick as quickly
it shouldn't all be put on that because
things take time
time for young voters to build new
habits and for
parties to engage with new voters
crystal gomencing global news cardiff
wales
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada
is this abandoned schoolhouse near pence
saskatchewan
thanks for watching farah nasser will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow and i will
see you on saturday for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye